bruno fait partie du club cyclotourisme
de nous re pas depuis un temps un
collectionne les vélos anciens géants
mais 110 à peu près à la maison ben
entre 1881 le granby j'ai aussi une des
premières bicyclettes de 1887 89 jusqu'à
des vélos de 1960 c'est ma date de
naissance j'avais mille le couperet à
cette date là voilà c'était symbolique
aujourd'hui bruno a prêté neuf lots à
ses camarades
habillés à la mode du siècle dernier et
malgré les apparences entre vélo
modernes ou anciens ils ont tranché les
moddeurs mais c'est comme entre une
jeune femme et des femmes au roi père
john et les femmes justement il y en
avait à maurepas au total 200 venus de
rennes
nous on est venu de bretagne avec
quelques copines quand on est à nos
portes bagages
on prépare cette manifestation piana
catherine et véronique les deux jumelles
ont mis à jour et demi pour parcourir
300 km pour elle et toutes les autres
femmes c'est une grande première
la fédération a décidé de promouvoir le
vélo féminin et donc du coup c'est bah
c'est une grande fête pour les fans
parce que ça permet à certaines comme
jamais rouler en groupe
moi jamais roulé dans des paquets ou
avec des clubs de pouvoir découvrir ce
que c'est que le boulot sur plusieurs
jours cours de mécanique et entraînement
au vélo les femmes n'ont rien à envier à
la gente masculine
c'est différent d'être entre filles ah
oui ça ça pierre beaucoup dans le
peloton ça chante et ça c'est fait mais
le portier breton a quitté mon repas
dans la joie et la bonne humeur
direction versailles avant de rejoindre
la tour eiffel où près de 5000 féminines
venues de tout l'hexagone se sont donné
rendez vous pour célébrer le
cyclotourisme au féminin